It really pains me to have to talk about this
today.
It really does.
But I'm really worried about a faction of
my audience and, and quite frankly, I'm really
worried about the left and this is not concerned
trolling.
I'm worried because of the response to a video
that I did yesterday explaining some unfortunate
realities about Medicare for all.
I did a video yesterday where I explained
in no uncertain terms, we're not getting Medicare
for all anytime soon.
Now there are lots of good progressive takes
that agree with that.
One example is a progressive economists, Dean
Baker's recent comments about Medicare for
all he, he is a progressive.
I had him on the show recently.
There was no question about it.
I did the video in good faith.
I said, listen, I'm for Medicare for all.
I believe Medicare for all is the gold standard.
I want Medicare for all.
I'm not suggesting that we push lame centrist
policy because getting Medicare for all will
take much longer than some people think.
I'm not suggesting that we don't hold our
candidates accountable to the gold standard.
That is Medicare for all.
But I explained to some unfortunate realities
about Medicare for all with the hope that
once we all understand these, we can be stronger
in our advocacy for better policy as activists,
as media people, as voters, people in the
audience.
The video I did is about 10 minutes long and
I expected that there would be some comments
and David, you're kind of being a defeatist
here even though it's not what I'm, what I'm
actually doing.
Uh, but the reaction has been, um, again,
it's just from a piece of my audience.
A lot of people understood what I was doing
and appreciated it.
Three minutes after the video was published.
Remember the video is 10 minutes long, three
minutes after the video was published.
It had 50 dislikes.
It's only been three minutes.
You couldn't possibly have watched the 10
minute video.
Even if you had it on double time on YouTube
in the three minutes it took 50 people to
dislike the video.
And there are either people who didn't watch
the video at all or people who just watched
it and don't understand what I'm saying or
people making bad faith arguments.
But I am very worried because if that is the
contingent that the success of our movement
depends on, we will lose.
And I hate to say that.
Let me give you some examples and um, uh,
again I'm doing this because I want to win
and I'm worried that there are factions in
our movement that are totally misguided and
their reactions to, to, to people simply saying,
Hey guys, we should be aware of this stuff.
One example, I'm not surprised David is shilling
against Medicare.
I actually say in the video probably close
to a dozen times I am for Medicare for all
this is either an ignorant or a bad faith
comment.
Another user responded, Bernie can establish
a state of emergency and sign it into law.
Trump has set so many precedents.
Listen, this is where the the the, there is
an element of the left that is in a fantasy
world.
We are not going to get Medicare for all established
through a presidential state of emergency.
I understand that there's some hypothetical
world in which president Bernie Sanders says,
our uh, healthcare situation is so bad that
I'm declaring a state of emergency and during
that state of emergency I am going to simply
create Medicare for all and then boom, we
will have Medicare for all.
It's just unrealistic.
Okay?
It's not worth even putting energy into that
and responding to what I'm talking about by
saying, David, Bernie will just declare a
state of emergency and create Medicare for
all.
It's not happening.
We are not going to win if that's what we
are hoping for or waiting for.
Another example, this was a very bad take
and a bad faith argument.
David [inaudible].
What was bad faith about it?
They don't say, this sounds like a Nancy Pelosi
speech.
Please go back to being more progressive.
People liked you more that way.
I mean, listen, the show is bigger than ever.
It's more than doubled in the last year, but
that's not really the, actually don't think
that's the issue.
That doesn't tell us whether I'm right or
wrong.
The idea that it's a bad faith argument when
I'm saying I'm for Medicare for all, we should
still push for Medicare for all.
We should demand our candidates before Medicare
for all.
That is what seems like bad faith to me.
Uh, another comment.
Okay.
So David is basically advocating for centrist
policies so that we have a chance in the future.
No, I literally say in the video, I am not
suggesting that we advocate for centrist policies.
I say it in the video.
So again, either people aren't listening or
they're making bad faith arguments.
And lastly, now is the time to unsubscribe
from this channel.
Do this to be making a point.
No progressive should ever be posting against
Medicare for all.
So again, number one, I say a dozen times
in the video, I'm for Medicare for all.
But more importantly, that is the sort of
black and white thinking, these these bogus
litmus tests that are not connected to reality.
Not only am I for Medicare for all, I'm trying
to figure out the right way to get there.
One idea I had is it's more likely to start
with a state doing Medicare for all.
That was one example that I gave.
Now, fortunately I did get some emails from
people who took the time to email me and say,
David, I know you're going to get crap for
this, but you're right and I think it's good
that you're doing it.
We need to be more armed with facts so that
we can better advocate for what we want.
There were a few YouTube comments that that
seemed to understand what was going on.
One who said these comments show people don't
listen to what he's saying.
Yeah.
Another comment or who said the comments are
depressing.
Watch the whole video.
He supports Medicare for all.
He's talking about strategy here.
He's talking about reality.
He's right.
He's saying it because people need to know
the reality.
We need realistic expectations and knowledge
about how the system works, so listen, I'm
not being, I'm not acting in bad faith.
I'm saying a Bernie presidency doesn't get
it for us, for all of the reasons that I cited
yesterday and more I want it.
I think it's the best.
Listen to what I'm saying.
It's not impossible.
It's just way more work and we need to know
that going in and we aren't going to succeed
in any of this.
If we imagine such delusional things, as Bernie
will say, we have an emergency and put in
Medicare for all, it's not going to happen.
It's not going to happen.
An any time wasted expecting that or suggesting
that is time that you are distracting from
doing the real work that needs to be done.
Prove me wrong.
I want to be wrong.
Okay?
This is one of those things where if in three
years we have Medicare for all, I will gladly
show up and say, you know what?
I was skeptical but I was wrong.
You all great activists prove me wrong and
we have Medicare for all.
I hope that that happens, but it's not going
to be closer to a reality if the reaction
is David, you shouldn't even allude to the
fact that it might be more difficult than
some people are making it out to be.
Spend the time advocating for a groundswell
of progressive candidates at all levels, all
of whom want Medicare for all so that we can
take back the white house and the Senate and
governor's mansions and the Supreme court,
which will be crucial in actually getting
working Medicare for all.
But if the reason, uh, if the reaction to
me being realistic is, David, you're a shill.
You're a bad person for doing this.
You shouldn't be saying this, I'm now a right
winger or a centrist or whatever.
We will lose if we attack people who agree
with us on policy, not because they even disagree
on one policy, but because they differently
assess its path to reality, they will crush
us.
They will crush us.
We will lose if that's what we do.
Mark my words, we will forget about Medicare
for all.
Trump will get reelected.
We will not get the Senate.
It is upsetting to see, and I'll go even further.
I've talked before about how our system is
set up to prevent people from really activating
what we really need are mass rallies in urban
centers.
We need to consider strategic defaults to
cripple the financial system, mass work call-outs
to cripple industry, serious forms of protest.
But as I've said before, the system is designed,
designed so that no one can afford to do that
by keeping wages stagnant, keeping public
transit terrible in most places.
And the rest of it, we've talked about it
before.
Let's work together because the reaction to
yesterday's video from this piece of my audience
is how we end up accomplishing nothing.
And I don't want to accomplish nothing.
I am not suggesting we give up on anything.
Should we fight for Medicare for all?
Yes, we should.
Should we always start negotiations from the
morally correct position that we actually
believe in?
Is Medicare for all of course, but responding
with kill the messenger too.
I think some people are missing the reality
of how this becomes, uh, the law, how this
becomes our status quo.
It's toxic and it will destroy the left, which
I don't want to see and I would actually argue
that the left has already been hurt by the
significantly on the positions we are already
with the majority of the country.
Every poll tells us on healthcare, we are
with the majority on gun safety.
We are with the majority.
One of the reasons there are many reasons
and many of them are structural and know gerrymandering
and campaign finance.
One of the reasons why we have not been more
effective is this infighting that exists.
When someone says, Hey, I'm with you on everything
except I disagree about how easy you think
it's going to be and here's what we need to
know.
We're going to lose, we're going to lose and
I don't want to lose.
Tell me all the ways that I'm wrong.
If you can actually keep it issue-based.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Leave a reply below.
I'm sure that there will be more followup
about this upcoming,